today you and I are gonna get into divergence
and curl to make sure we're all on the same
page let's begin by talking about vector fields
essentially a vector field is what you get if
you associate each point in space with a vector
some magnitude and direction maybe those vectors
represent the velocities of particles of fluid
at each point in space or maybe they represent
the force of gravity at many different points in
space or maybe a magnetic field strength quick
note on drawing these often if you were to draw
the vectors to scale the longer ones end up just
cluttering up the whole thing so it's common to
basically lie a little and artificially shorten
ones that are too long maybe using color
to give some vague sense of length now in
principle vector fields and physics might change
over time in almost all real world fluid flow the
velocities of particles in a given region of
space will change over time in response to the
surrounding context wind is not a constant it
comes in gusts an electric field changes as the
charged particles characterizing it move around
but here we'll just be looking at static vector
fields which maybe you think of as describing
a steady state system also while such vectors
could in principle be three-dimensional or
even higher we're just going to be looking
at two dimensions an important idea which
regularly goes unsaid is that you can often
understand a vector field which represents one
physical phenomenon better by imagining what if
it represented a different physical phenomenon
what if these vectors describing gravitational
force instead defined a fluid flow what would that
flow look like and what can the properties of that
float tell us about the original gravitational
force and what if the vectors defining a fluid
flow were thought of as describing the downhill
direction of a certain hill does such a hill even
exist and if so what does it tell us about
the original flow these sorts of questions
can be surprisingly helpful for example the
ideas of divergence and curl are particularly
viscerally understood when the vector field is
thought of as representing fluid flow even if
the field you're looking at is really meant to
describe something else like an electric field
here take a look at this vector field and think
of each vector as describing the velocity of a
fluid at that point notice that when you do this
that fluid behaves in a very strange non-physical
way around some points like these ones the
fluid seems to just spring into existence
from nothingness as if there's some kind of
source there some other points act more like
sinks where the fluid seems to disappear into
nothingness the divergence of a vector field at
a particular point of the plane tells you how
much this imagined fluid tends to flow out of
or into small regions near it for example the
divergence of our vector field evaluated at
all of those points that act like sources will
give a positive number and it doesn't just have
to be that all of the fluid is flowing away from
that point the divergence would also be positive
if it was just that the fluid coming into it from
one direction was slower than the flow coming out
of it in another direction since that would still
insinuate a certain spontaneous generation now on
the flip side if in a small region around a point
there seems to be more fluid flowing into it than
out of it the divergence at that point would be
a negative number remember this vector field is
really a function that takes in two dimensional
inputs and spits out two dimensional outputs the
divergence of that vector field gives you a new
function one that takes in a single 2d point as
its input but its output depends on the behavior
of the field in a small neighborhood around that
point in this way it's analogous to a derivative
and that output is just a single number measuring
how much that point acts as a source or a sink
and purposely delaying discussion of computations
here the understanding for what it represents
is more important notice this means that for
an actual physical fluid like water rather than
some imagined one used to illustrate an arbitrary
vector field then if that fluid is incompressible
the velocity vector field must have a divergence
of zero of where that's an important constraint on
what kinds of vector fields could solve real-world
fluid flow problems for the curl at a given point
you also think about the fluid flow around it but
this time you asked how much that fluid tends to
rotate around the point as in if you were to drop
a twig in the fluid at that point somehow fixing
its center in place would it tend to spin around
regions where that rotation is clockwise are
said to have positive curl and regions where
it's counterclockwise have negative curl and
it doesn't have to be that all of the vectors
around the input are pointing counterclockwise
or all of them are pointing clockwise a point
inside a region like this one for example would
also have nonzero curl since the flow is slow
at the bottom but quick up top resulting in a
net clockwise influence and really true proper
curl is a three dimensional idea one where you
associate each point in 3d space with a new vector
characterizing the rotation around that point
according to a certain right hand rule and I have
plenty of content from my time at Khan Academy
describing this in more detail if you want but
for our main purpose I'll just be referring to the
two dimensional variant of curl which associates
each point in 2d space with a single number
rather than a new vector as I said even though
these intuitions are given in the context of fluid
flow both of these ideas are significant for other
sorts of vector fields one very important example
is how electricity and magnetism are described by
for special equations these are known as Maxwell's
equations and they're written in the language of
divergence and curl this top one for example is
Gauss's law stating that the divergence of an
electric field at a given point is proportional
to the charge density at that point unpacking the
intuition for this you might imagine positively
charged regions as acting like sources of some
imagined fluid and negatively charged regions as
being the sinks of that fluid and throughout parts
of space where there is no charge the fluid would
be flowing in compressively just like water of
course there's not some literal electric fluid but
it's a very useful and a very pretty way to read
an equation like this similarly another important
equation is that the divergence of the magnetic
field is zero everywhere and you can understand
that by saying that if the field represents a
fluid flow that fluid would be incompressible with
no sources and no sinks it acts just like water
this also has the interpretation that magnetic
monopoles something that acts just like a north
or a south end of a magnet in isolation don't
exist there's nothing analogous to positive and
negative charges in an electric field likewise
the last two equations tell us that the way that
one of these fields changes depends on the curl
of the other field and really this is a purely
three-dimensional idea and a little outside of our
main focus here but the point is that divergence
and curl arise in contexts that are unrelated to
flow and side note the back and forth from these
last two equations is what gives rise to light
waves and quite often these ideas are useful in
contexts which don't even seem spatial in nature
at first to take a classic example that students
of differential equations often studied let's say
that you wanted to track the population sizes of
two different species where maybe one of them is
a predator of another the state of this system
at a given time meaning the two population sizes
can be thought of as a point in two-dimensional
space what you would call the phase space of this
system for a given pair of population sizes these
populations may be inclined to change based on
things like how reproductive are the two species
or just how much does one of them enjoy eating the
other one these rates of change would typically
be written analytically as a set of differential
equations it's okay if you don't understand these
particular equations I'm just throwing them up
for those of you who are curious and because we're
placing variables with pictures makes me laugh a
little bit but the relevance here is that a nice
way to visualize what such a set of equations is
really saying is to associate each point on the
plane each pair of population sizes with a vector
indicating the rates of change for both variables
for example when there are lots of foxes but
relatively few rabbit the number of foxes might
tend to go down because of the constrained food
supply and the number of rabbits might also tend
to go down because they're getting eaten by all
of the foxes potentially at a rate that's faster
than they can reproduce so a given vector here
is telling you how and how quickly a given pair
of population sizes tends to change notice this
is a case where the vector field is not about
physical space but instead it's a representation
of a certain dynamic system that has two variables
and how that system evolves over time this can
maybe also give a sense for why mathematicians
care about studying the geometry of higher
dimensions what if our system was tracking
more than just two or three numbers now the flow
associated with this field is called the phase
flow for our differential equation and it's a way
to conceptualize at a glance how many possible
starting States would evolve over time operations
like divergence and curl can help to inform you
about the system do the population sizes tend to
converge towards a particular pair of numbers or
there are some values that they diverge away from
are there cyclic patterns and are those cycles
stable or unstable to be perfectly honest with
you for something like this you'd often want to
bring in related tools beyond just divergence and
curl those would give you the full story but the
frame of mind that practice with these two ideas
brings you carries over well to studying setups
like this with similar pieces of mathematical
machinery now if you really want to get a handle
on these ideas you'd want to learn how to compute
them and to practice those computations and I'll
leave some links to where you can learn about
this and practice if you want again I did some
videos and articles and worked examples for Khan
Academy on this topic during my time there so too
much detail here we'll start to feel redundant
for me but there is one thing worth bringing
up regarding the notation associated with these
computations commonly the divergence is written
as a dot product between this upside-down triangle
thing and your vector field function and the curl
is written as a similar cross product sometimes
students are told that this is just a notational
trick each computation involves a certain
sum of certain derivatives and treating this
upside-down triangle as if it was a vector of
Rivet evaporators can be a helpful way to keep
everything straight but it is actually more than
just a mnemonic device there is a real connection
between divergence and the dot product and between
curl and the cross product even though we won't be
doing practice computations here I would like
to give you at least some vague sense for how
these four ideas are connected imagine taking
some small step from one point of your vector
field to another the vector at this new point
will likely be a little bit different from the
one at the first point there will be some change
to the function after that step which you might
see by subtracting off your original vector from
that new one and this kind of difference to your
function over small steps is what differential
calculus is all about now the dot product gives
you kind of a measure of how aligned two vectors
are right now the dot product of your step vector
with that difference vector that it causes tends
to be positive in regions where the divergence is
positive and vice versa in fact in some sense
the divergence is a sort of average value for
this dot product of a step with a change to
the output that it causes over all possible
step directions assuming that things are rescaled
appropriately I mean think about it if a step in
some direction causes a change to that vector
in that same direction this corresponds to a
tendency for outward flow for positive divergence
and on the flip side if those dot products tend
to be negative meaning the difference vector
is pointing in the opposite direction from the
step vector that corresponds with a tendency
for inward flow negative divergence similarly
remember that the cross product is a sort of
measure for how perpendicular two vectors are
so the cross product of your step vector with
the difference vector that it causes tends to
be positive in regions where the curl is positive
and vice versa you might think of the curl as a
sort of average of this step vector difference
vector cross product if a step in some direction
corresponds to a change perpendicular to that step
that corresponds to a tendency for flow rotation
so typically this is the part where there might
be some kind of sponsor message but one thing I
want to do with the channel moving ahead is to
stop doing sponsored content and instead make
things just about the direct relationship with the
audience I mean that not only in the sense of the
funding model with direct support through patreon
but also in the sense that I think these videos
can better accomplish their goal if each one of
them feels like it's just about you and me sharing
in a love of math with no other motive especially
in the cases where the viewers are students there
are some other reasons and I wrote up some of
my full thoughts on this over on patreon which
you certainly don't have to be a supporter to read
that's just where it lives I think advertising on
the Internet occupies a super wide spectrum from
truly degenerate clickbait up to genuinely well
aligned win-win-win partnerships now I've always
taken care to do promotions for companies that I
would genuinely recommend to take one example you
may have noticed that I did a number of promos for
a brilliant and it's really hard to imagine better
alignment than that right I mean I try to inspire
people to be interested in math but I'm also
a firm believer that videos aren't enough that
you need to actively solve problems and here's a
platform that provides practice and likewise for
any others I've promoted too I always make sure
to feel good alignment but even still even if you
seek out the best possible partnerships whenever
advertising is in the equation the incentives
will always be to try reaching as many people as
possible but when the model is more exclusively
about a direct relationship with the audience
the incentives are pointed towards maximizing how
valuable people find the experiences that they're
given and I think those two goals are correlated
but not always perfectly I like to think that I'll
always try to maximize the value of the experience
no matter what but for that matter I also like
to think that I can consistently wake up early
and resist eating too much sugar what matters
more than wanting something is to actually align
incentives anyway if you want to hear more of my
thoughts all linked to the patreon post and thank
you again to existing supporters for making
this possible and I'll see you all next video